it is often said that clothes make the
man and nowhere is that truer than in
the case of superheroes and their
costumes on Cape Jolin join me today as
we take a closer look at the history of
the bat suit now you may all be
fascinated to learn that Batman's iconic
costume actually has its roots in the
Italian Renaissance now I'm serious Bob
Kane and Bill Finger drew much
inspiration not only from the pulp
heroes of the time like Zorro and even
the shadow but also from the famous
plans of painter Leonardo da Vinci's
flying machine and really do you need
any more proof of what I'm saying than
to look at this early concept piece for
Batman yes Batman was originally
supposed to have blond hair and instead
of a cape big uncomfortable-looking
wings
luckily saner heads would prevail and
Batman would premiere in 1939 with a
costume closer to what we all know and
love today some items that were lost
over time include the purple gloves and
the much bigger Longer Battier's on the
cow those would be trimmed down to a
more reasonable size Bruce Wayne's
reason for adopting the bat gimmick was
tied to a bat crashing through the
window of his dead father's study
giving our would-be hero the perfect
symbol to terrify criminals with now
while every artist may have their own
individual take on the outfit what we
know for sure is the suit is made of a
triple weave Kevlar or some other such
material depending on which era were in
the kevlar of course offers our hero
bullet resistance around his most
sensitive areas mainly being the shed
over the 75 Aude years the character of
Batman has been around our hero has
taken to updating and modifying the suit
as circumstance dictates some of the
more outlandish modifications include
things like propellers in his shoes for
when he needs to move fast on water
antennas in the cowl for communication
purposes and even knock out gas vents on
his gloves and even a built-in
electrical system to shock would-be
assailant in the 1970s famous comic
artist Neil Adams whose would put his
own spin on the bat suit in such major
ways as having the cloak becoming a more
scalloped edge cape the gloves becoming
gauntlets was three claws on the edges
these claws were supposedly meant to
help Batman in his climbing and it's
also been shown time and time again that
in a pinch Batman can stop a bladed
weapon with these gauntlets the cape and
cowl of this era was now bright blue and
the bat symbol had a yellow Eclipse
around it this costume made from
very unique fire retardant and chemical
retardant triple weave Kevlar thread was
also said to have carbon nanotube fibers
that imparted it with a unique Sheen and
made it very hard to rip the 1990s would
be a period of much change for Batman
and indeed comics as a whole this period
would see Batman ditch his blue duds
completely in exchange for a more
full-on black attire this new costume
seen most prominently in the troika
storyline also found Batman abandoning
his briefs on the outside a standard for
almost all the major DC heroes
eventually the boots and gloves would
return to no longer making the suit and
look like one solid piece but it would
still be a few more years before bats
put his trunks back on still in my mind
that probably wasn't the biggest Batman
fashion faux-pas of that time need I
remind you of his JLA era getup when his
shoulders had Gothic spikes on them for
some reason as of the 2000 around the
storyline no man's land Batman's costume
would undergo yet another change the
blue and the briefs were back but the
yellow circle around the bat symbol had
been removed this was seen as an attempt
to return to a more original classic
looking Batman costume it should also be
noted that the utility belt was now more
in line with the one scene in the story
Batman year one now during the events of
2009 Grant Morrison's story Batman r.i.p
after getting dosed with powerful
psychotropic drugs Batman believing
himself to be the Batman of Zarina
Dawn's a multicolored monstrosity this
costume itself being a reference to much
older much campy ER Batman stories now
after his apparent death of the hands of
Darkseid in Final Crisis the so called a
final bat suit was put on display in the
Batcave making it so Bruce Wayne spear
could be felt throughout the entire bat
family of course Bruce Wayne wasn't
really dead just lost in time and trying
on a bunch of different period outfits
while he was at it and when he finally
did return he got himself yet another
new costume prominently featured in the
pages of Batman Incorporated this new
suit designed by David Finch offered an
opportunity to help differentiate Batman
from all the other members of the ever
growing Batman Inc and even Dick Grayson
who had donned his own costume during
his
mentor's absence the yellow bat symbol
was back and bigger than ever there were
blue lungs juxtaposed to an even
brighter shade of gray and the belt
looked now even more high-tech than it
ever had before when DC Comics rebooted
in 2014 as part of the new 52 initiative
almost all the heroes got new costumes
including Batman himself the new 52 suit
managed to marry a lot of what fans
loved about older suits and now featured
no briefs and an even more armored
appearance courtesy of Jim Lee and
that's pretty much the entire history of
Batman's bat suit right up until the
time of this recording now obviously
this is a huge topic and I was only able
to scratch the surface you know I didn't
include such one-off costumes like the
suit of saw rose or the Tengu ninja
outfit because well mainly if you ask me
those are episodes in their own right
same with other characters who have worn
the Batman costume like daming in the
alternate future and even John Paul
Valley Ezreal ditto goes for all the
armored bat suits and warm acts like
from Dark Knight Returns and end games
plus the mountains of movies and video
games and cartoons this is really a
topic that keeps on giving and something
I will have to revisit at some point in
the future but until then everyone I
hope you enjoyed the video I hope you
learned a little something and until
next time this is cape joel out